heard from the proposition that actually
what really mattered for a government
was how much power it has but what we
didn't hear was any analysis of how
having the people backing you gives you
more power not only on the international
stage with international relations but
also within your own country when you're
sort of standing up to Global
corporations and stuff and I was
wondering whether they should offer us
any discussion can I immediately swing
in if you look at I believe it's
um
800 million Indians will be voting in
their election coming up or at least are
entitled to vote over 800 million where
is India at the international bodies
like the United Nations security Council
if numbers and democracy count or did
count for your weight in the world about
decisions that def affect the fortunes
of everybody in the world the
democracies don't get in there the big
ones
it's a little one like this one